[Musique]
est ce que vous vous rappelez de la
vidéo de david guetta bien oui david
guetta que vous avez laissé une petite
vidéo regardez à lui les poteaux c'est
david guetta gilles pour ton enterrement
de vie de garçon
eh bien on va se faire ibiza mais chez
toi dans ton appart et ça va être génial
waouh jean je le suis déjà chaud en
hiver
[Applaudissements]
gilles oui c'est françois viaud qui vous
aime beaucoup
en fait il ya le vrai david guetta xive
où il avait laissé une vidéo où la
remettra quand on partira vraiment
gilles vous avez été bien dans le centre
de paris
oui oui la porte de votre immeuble elle
est bien bleu oui deux pièces oui
j'étais un des seuls au monde à encore
avoir un magnétoscope
comment vous savez ça vous c'est tout
vous avez un canapé gris avec des
coussins rouges dans votre cuisine vous
avez toujours un carrelage blanc et
jaune
oui votre maman elle était chez vous
aujourd'hui
oui elle est sympa ce qu'elle a accepté
d'aller à l'hôtel pour nous laisser
votre appartement
parce que jean c est bizarre
vous vouliez pas là et bizarre vous avez
dit à la rentrée donc on s'est dit il
faut qu'ils aillent chez lui ah oui
jean-michel bah oui oui je regarde
tellement je suis content j'avais
jean-michel franches aux abattoirs
on y va après vous voulez aller chez lui
un frère un papa j'aimerais bien ouais
si les boeufs boys alors c est bizarre
chez lui avec le sable à tout ça vous
fait ça on y va janvier après banco ça
vous fait kiffer ben hmida mamba va
aussi regarder si c'est pas
[Musique]
m
je
dimanche ont passé une super soirée chez
toi tu m'as bien trouve cette année est
rallongé tourisme aparté regarde surtout
et s'évanouit yens
on va nous pousser
allez je te fais visiter je suivais
visités par le monde un regard chez toi
aller j'étais une piscine dans ton
premier salut salut j'ai géré mon projet
et voilà pascal
il est contrôlé ces jours on passe qu'un
plus offrant
joli jamie tu m'entends janvier arrêter
la musique quelque chose chez toi jean
mi mai lors s est passé attendez
attendez attendez attendez attendez
attendez c'est chez gilles ça oui non
c'est chez qui ça oui sur noir
[Applaudissements]
attention
ouais
[Applaudissements]
oui
jean-mi gens me gêne pour les voisins
sûr je suis super mal avec les oiseaux
après cette superbe avec vous arrivez
fracassé la porte du parking a pas
longtemps je passe à travers voiture on
n'a pas réussi à avoir les clés jim est
légitime et j'ai gonflé non bas et à
votre ex femme qui a toujours la clé
bien c'est la vengeance constance
bref allez là que naît quand même et au
pape le dire françois viaud qui a été
très bonne allure
avant de partir j'avais un cheikh lô
champs est en train de faire la fête
vous inquiétez pas c'est le seul chez
vous fera des petits points dans la part
de jean michel maire pendant la soirée
le sont moins forts non non c'est génial
comme j'ai quand ce bon 3e claouey quoi
mais non c'est un joli 6 mois ce qui est
rouge fait trop de bruit déjà ça oui non
mais là vous pouvez dire c'est pas moi
ah oui c'est vrai tu content ça va
passer crème